hello everybody good morning
I'm Alessia and today I would like to
talk about versioning in the data
science world and since we're talking
about versioning I'm assuming a bit of
knowledge about Kate in the audience but
in case not don't worry he is a brief
recap Sookie is a free and open source
distributed version control system and
the first thing you can do but kate is
either creating a new repository in
which kit in it our or clone an existing
one the local repository consists of
three trees the first one is the working
directory which contains the actual
files then there is the index which acts
as a staging area for your files and
finally the head pointing to the last
comments you've made the tree must use
comments git add commit and push and as
names are suggesting you can propose
changes with git add commit them using
git commit and sending your changes to
remote repository using git push
branches are essentially a unique set of
code changes with a unique name and are
used to double features is related from
each other to create a new branch let's
say called feature X you can run git
checkout - be feature X do all your
stuff and then go back to master we'd
get checkout master master is the
default branch forget to update your
local repository you can run git pull
for merging you have git merge and view
the changes you have made relative to
the index you can run git diff one of
the first things that comes to mind when
thinking about versioning is code right
and in particular one of the first thing
that comes to
when thinking about data science is
Jupiter notebook it's one of the most
used tool for experimenting in data
science they're great they contain
source code markdown plots and it's very
handy to have all of these things in one
place but the reality is that in this
case you cannot manage versioning as you
would do with regular Python scripts
because at very end they are nothing
more than a JSON file and it is not able
to understand the structure of your
notebook so you cannot simply add a
notebook to your repo apron then it's
alright what happens if you change the
order of the imports in a source code
cell and change name of the executing
environment for example well the diff is
still understandable right but what
happened when you try to change the
order of two cells and relating another
one the result is that the SIM code is
added and deleted but let's move on to
an example of a bit more data science
oriented we have an array containing
numbers from 1 to 9 and we want to plot
the square of this array this is what we
get now we change our mind we want to
block the thirds power of the array this
is what we get if you have diff while
the only bit of useable information is
containing these two lines
what a mess right the first tool I'm
presenting to you today that will
hopefully improve your life if you're
working with Ruby or notebooks is called
MB time it provides content-aware
defined emerging of Jupiter notebooks
because it understand the structure of
your JSON file it's people storable and
it provides the way to give your
notebooks the first one is in the bra in
terminal as usual but also in a browser
as we saw in the previous slide the cool
thing is that it fully integrates with
git so you don't have to worry anymore
Oh some right this is the diff that Envy
damn shows way much better but when it
comes to data science we know that not
only the code is involved in the process
also the data used to perform the
experiments plays a crucial role so
imagine this setting we have a data set
theta dot CSV let's say a bunch of
numbers with some metadata and now you
pre-processing your data set the screen
the numbers to rain 0 to 1 and you
perform some checks damn you find some
incorrect data and then you decide you
want to remove them you investigate a
little bit more and you find some
outliers in your data set and you decide
to remove them too now you have your
data set wrap up and running this is a
quite simple scenario but if you're not
careful enough you could end up messing
up things very very easily so how do you
cryptic tracks of changes in your data
here is where hunger comes into place
this this is a very young project born
only six months ago but in my opinion is
very promising
it's basically provides support for
versioning your data in a smart way it
is designed to solve many of the problem
faced with regular code versioning
systems just adapted to numerical data
so time travel to see the circle changes
of your data set zero cost branching
merging to build the data set over time
or with multiple collaborators and so on
it is based on the concept of resets
where an array set is a grouping of
similar type of information so you
we are working with images it were most
likely to have an eraser with tencel
representing the images another one
containing filenames and last one
containing labels and sin so each were a
set is a separated entity hunger
provides also a way to efficiently store
your data using different backends you
may want to save your images in hdf5
format while your file names using anti
rate and labels using tied to be hunger
enables to save recently your data you
don't have everything even you have to
think about it because the interaction
with the backend is totally transparent
with the user so let's see how it work
you import the Hunger repository you
associated given the path to the
repository and utilize it providing your
name and your email you check out into
this repository keeping lock on writing
and let's say you want to load your
images using numpy then you initialize a
new array set providing the name and a
prototype you need to specify a
prototype which is an element of your
collection so hunger can know the shape
and the type of the elements and so
decide for the best back-end for storing
your data now we want to add elements to
our race and hunger accept both drinks
and integer keys or we can leverage the
add API we commit our changes and we
close to lip-lock now let's watch a
branching emerging features you create a
new dummy array we
range from zero to nine we create a new
array set and as before we commit and
then we close we create a new branch
called US branch and we check out into
this branch and we verified that the
array set we created before contains
exactly what believe is containing and
then we create a new array with numbers
ranging from one to ten and we assign it
to the second as the second element of
the array set we commit and then we go
back to master and we merge that's it
and are also let you to work with remote
storage and the first thing you need to
do is starting an anger server by
default is server the server is bound to
the port 505 one so the first thing you
the second thing you have to do is these
remotes to your repository and then you
can push your changes so now in another
folder or in another machine you can
clone your repository but this operation
retrieves only commits records and
history and you don't have the actual
data if you want to download the data
you need to call fetch data explicitly
but the cool thing here is that you can
specify the number of bytes you want to
retrieve or you might want to fetch if
you if you want to have only a closer
look to some files to see if they
actually storing as you as my thing
the last useful feature is that you can
easily integrate anger into your
existing pipeline thanks to these api's
make TF dataset or make that towards
datasets with return of tensorflow
or pythor's data set from
hunger erasers so now can you remember
the previous setting with all the
dataset changes yeah now we know hangar
that is able to track all our changes
for data fantastic but how are we done
not really if we look at the whole
picture and not only individual pieces
we notice that there's a lot more going
on in fact we consider only the inputs
the data and the transformation function
that operates on this data the code but
not at the outputs this could be the
reality so at this point you may be
wondering how to link code data
resulting models and metrics but most
importantly will you be able to
replicate all your experiments a year
from now well I used to use this kind of
spreadsheet where you annotate your
experiments what our network
architecture you were using the data set
metrics and so on but trust me is a
nightmare
because how easy is to mess up with rows
or copy/paste the wrong column dvc to
the rescue DBC is able to manage this
kind of issues and provides a general
view over what's going on with your
machine learning project it works with
any framework you may have and is
designed to run on top of git
repositories but I have a little short
video for you data science is exciting
you get a data simple to find the goal
in date of features clean them up and
make your setup ready to go processes
through the machine learning algorithm
get the results display the results and
you have found some cool insights so you
can take a break but a couple days later
a colleague of yours could ask have you
cleaned this feature from the noise oh
no it seems like you over wrote
something a couple dependencies are
missing and the old file you used before
kind of stinks well you have a lot and
you wrote down every step you took so
that you your colleagues and your future
self can pick up at any point of the
experiment but you still lose time on
processing which can take forever but
don't worry we found a fix for you data
version control is an open source
experimentation tool it helps you the
scientist define your pipeline no matter
what language you use swish it is based
on git but supports large files get in
reproducibility warp you to any prior
stage of your project without model
retraining like a time machine but in
all seriousness anyone can use it
so the process of fixing mistakes is
much easier now versions become
shareable swish problems become fixable
[Music]
switch and collaboration is now simpler
than ever before or more simple it's
just the best that's ever been
a data version-control calm pretty
impressive right so how does it work the
first of all in a git repository
you have to initialize also DBC repo
then you have to choose your remote or
DBC can store your data so let's say
let's go with AWS and then go with a
common DBC remote hat great how can you
add data to DBC then DBC ad creates a
DBC file and a data
slash data dot CSV to the git ignore the
VC files are small text text files with
human readable format that stores the
information about your data and then can
and they can be committed to get to
approach to data for remote just go for
DBC push if you want to retrieve your
data from the remote storage you can use
TVC pool or DBC pool followed by inter
DBC files that describe the exact file
you are looking for and the DVC run
common let you connect code and data and
also to specify dependencies and output
files or folders generated by the Python
comment and last but not least it
executes the comment the vc run
generates the file pre-process
pre-process underscore data dot d bc
which has the same format as the DBC
file we created before but has
additional information about the output
folder and the Python command required
to build it by using DBC run multiple
times a specified output of a common as
dependencies of another one you can
describe a sequence of comments to get
to a final result you are building a
dependency graph now as we have a number
of stage file that describe the full
pipeline its stream ly easy to rerun
your experiments and wend
using the DVC River comment train DBC
describes which source code and data
files are needed and how to run the
comments in order to get the final
result for each data files it vents on
it performed the same analysis so it
finds DBC files that includes the data
files its output and get dependencies
and comments and so on this means that
the VC is able to recursively build a
complete sequence of comments you need
to execute in order to get the model
file you can understand that the VC ran
and DBC repre are a powerful framework
for replicable experiments you can also
tag your experiments so in the future
you can retrieve all the data and code
used to perform the experiment to get
back to these initial experiment you run
git checkout along with the VC checkout
and you're done to conclude I think that
at the moment the general solution to
all of our problem does not exist yet
but the community is getting along and
it's becoming aware that as data
scientists we need a specific tool
designed to meet our needs because
honestly I don't want to spend any more
time trying to figure out if that
spreadsheet of experiment is still worth
my trust or not why would you thank you
[Applause]
questions there is one already so first
question that's this tool have any
deduplication makings maybe you know
because idea of sending old terabytes of
data to Amazon doesn't sound really good
for my salary is are you referring to
hunger or the TVC I think okay DBC is
based on hash mechanisms so if your data
set say you have one zip file and you
change a single data inside it the HD
hash changes right so it starts like
everything in in the role yes yes well
hunger behaves a little differently
because it stores tensors so you're able
to merge leaf all the things and the
second tiny question doesn't make more
sense to have a proper script how did I
clean the data than all the stages
because for me it seems more
reproducible when I have a script like
when I have an original data set and
script that actually did like final data
set yeah but the DVC files but what I
call stage files are only descriptors of
the the data file itself but it still
starts everything DVC yes okay having
sure I got a question okay maybe we can
talk offline
hi can you tell a bit about the
background of hangar how does it start
the data is it like a large file system
from get so if I think about machine
learning data
I think of gigabytes of data just per
day so don't we multiply these data in
the background if we store every step
[Music]
sure I got your question are you
referring to this same thing I think
it's it's close to the question yes so
if I modify my data and it's gigabytes
of data and I have ten steps in there to
modify them so I'm stirring ten times
the data in the background in the git
repository or hangar repository if you
want to you have the full freedom of
creating your array set or also the list
in them if you need them anymore so it's
up to you I think okay so I can delete
history No okay maybe we can talk off
learning them okay okay but thank you
just a single a very easy question
what's the advantage of using hangar
compared to DV see if TVC can also do
theta well I think that they're meant
for different purposes I will suggest
you to use hangar if your data set is
evolving very fast and you need to
control everything is going on but on
the other hand hunger does not provide
all the less a reproducible stuff up
there so hangar lets you store your data
efficiently depending on what kind of
data is DBC does not care so much about
this so it really depends on your just
case I think thank you for your talk in
a previous talk we were told that DBC
who does not have keeping track of the
metrics attached to some model so where
can we produce a model the presenter
said it was not possible to have the
metric know do you have a or to explore
the metrics after do you have do is that
do you have it experienced the same and
would you have a hint for that and we
see lets you attach metrics files that
are result of training let's say or
evaluation as you want to do with simple
files
I didn't attach the metrics step aside
but you can refer to the documentation
there is there are a couple of comments
to let you also compare them so you have
the full view over your experiments so
you can compare them
hi thanks Rach
do you know how AM DBC compares to other
technologies that to store large file
systems in get like get annex I don't
know that it's worth checking out okay
just you know if it doesn't perform if
there are no further questions then
let's thank Alice I again
[Music]
[Applause]